crecí tomando clases de arte todos los
sábados además de las clases normales
así es que dibuje y pinte bastante y
cuando estaba más grande me especialicé
en fotografía y en diseño
creo que siempre me han gustado los
rompecabezas y los acertijos son muy
lógicos y todo encaja perfecto creo que
esto es por lo que siempre me han
gustado las matemáticas siempre hay una
respuesta y puedes encontrarla y
resolver el problema bueno cuando estaba
en la universidad ni siquiera me
imaginaba que un trabajo como el que
tengo ahorita en pixar podría existir
estudié diseño gráfico y me encantó
luego cuando estaba terminando la
carrera me encontré con un estudio de
animación en columbus ohio que estaba
trabajando en la película space jam y la
idea de que alguien de mi ciudad
estuviera trabajando en una película me
encantó un día me aparecía en su puerta
literalmente toqué la puerta e intenté
obtener una pasantía pero nadie sabía
qué hacer conmigo me preguntaban quién
eres tú tienes una cita y yo les
contestaba no pero realmente quiero
trabajar aquí y como estaba tan
entusiasmada y estaban impresionados de
que estuviera buscando un trabajo de
verano en enero un año antes me dieron
ese trabajo de verano así es que trabajé
en ese estudio llamado
warner bros en columbus ohio por 10 años
y trabaje en muchos proyectos de
animación para la televisión y mientras
tanto la animación 3d se volvía cada vez
más popular y también más impresionante
y la verdad no sabía mucho del tema pero
tuve la suerte de que en mi segundo o
tercer año de posgrado vinieron
reclutadores de pixar a mi campus en la
universidad de ohio y me ofrecieron una
residencia como directora técnica
entonces cuando terminé mi maestría
llegué a pixar como residente y estado
aquí desde entonces
he estado en acabados y en peinados
empecé aquí en la película día y noche y
empecé haciendo los acabados de los
propios personajes algunas piezas del
escenario y también empecé a hacer los
peinados de ese proyecto y después
trabajé en varias presentaciones y
cortos como peinadora y como artista de
acabados de personajes los peinadores le
ponen el cabello y el pelaje a las cosas
si le damos un baño a un perro se ve
mucho más delgado por el pelo aplastado
lo mismo sucede con nuestros modelos
animales los cuerpos son mucho más
pequeños y tenemos que ponerles cabello
para obtener la silueta correcta a veces
es una mezcla entre modelar y hacer
acabados es cómo modelar porque te fijas
mucho en la silueta del personaje y en
hacer que la forma se vea bien pero
también eres una artista de acabados
porque eres el responsable de los
acabados de la superficie del objeto
y uno de mis favoritos fue art the
monsters university él fue un reto muy
divertido porque es como un arco y da
muchas vueltas diferentes así es que
tuvimos muchos retos para hacer que se
moviera adecuadamente y luego para hacer
que el pelo se viera bien con todos esos
picos en los lugares correctos fue muy
divertido trabajar con él trabaja tanto
como puedas encuentra tantas personas
con quiénes relacionarte como puedas que
hagan cosas que sientas que te inspiran
y rodéate de personas que son mejores
que tú porque harán que seas mejor en lo
que haces